a lot of the time we do have good ideas
but we are afraid of failing when I'm
not joyful I look at what happened we
have a dedicated section called good
news section it only has good news
what I'm telling you is to regularly
disconnect from technology to regularly
unplug and recharge in the end it's
about how we feel inside and what is it
that nourishes us Socrates said practice
death daily it's probably okay to be
upset and angry and irritated but how
long do you stay on it well first of all
I prioritize sleep it was when she was
in meditation that often a lot of his
best ideas for Apple came to him success
the way we've defined it is no longer
sustainable
she's a Greek American author syndicated
columnist and occasional actress she's a
co founder and editor-in-chief of The
Huffington Post
as of 2014 she is listed as a 52nd most
powerful woman in the world by Forbes
magazine
she's Arianna Huffington and here her
top 10 rules for success a lot of the
time we do have good ideas but we are
afraid of failing I think especially for
women and I see that in my daughters in
my daughters friends fear of failure is
what stops us more than anything
I agree and I was like in that I had a
mother who M was full of sort of this
colloquial wisdom and she used to say to
me you know failure is not the opposite
of success it's a stepping stone to
success there is nobody who has not
failed another way so I think it's very
important for young women especially as
they're starting in life and to
recognize that because otherwise they
only see people's successes so I when I
speak I speak of my failures and one
entry point is bringing joy back into
our everyday lives because so many of us
and I speak as a complete culprit you
know that as like a certifiable type
a workaholic driven personality who
basically felt my job was about getting
it all done getting it done in time
getting it accomplished and joy who has
time for joy and now I feel that not at
all that it's like when I'm not joyful I
look at what happened I don't mean I
don't mean joyful like there are no
challenges problems etc I mean like when
I'm not like hey this is great I'm
blessed I'm doing something I love I'm
grateful and when I don't have that
feeling and not I'm off I need to
course-correct so joy kind of really
checking in and seeing how am i doing am
i you don't even have to check in
because you know when you are in the
flow in the joy and when you're not what
I tell everyone who works with us is
that all the stuff that we've learned we
now need to apply to actually bringing
people to see how they can live their
lives in a better way and make the world
better so these things don't have to be
boring you know they can actually be
really exciting we have we have a
dedicated section called good news
section it only has good news it's one
of our most popular section
and I think part of it is because of the
zeitgeist you know I really believe in
the zeitgeist I mean a night a terrible
German word but but there is such a
thing as the zeitgeist you know the
spirit of the times this fruit of the
times is changing yeah and you see now
many brands want to be part of wellness
for example I mean when I decided to
launch the Huffington Post it was an
expensive operation and I had I wanted
to be free I was absolutely committed to
that I didn't want anybody to have to
pay for it because I wanted everybody to
be able to access it I never thought it
would be sponsored when we announced
that we're going to launch it at CES we
had brands competing to sponsor it it
ended up being sponsored by Weight
Watchers because of the connection
between stress and weight I really
believe that if we set up in the media
to do the right thing and do it
effectively and do it smartly and do it
in a way that draws people to it not in
a didactic way and the monetization will
follow if you look around you you see
leaders in positions of power in
politics in media in business all of
them with high IQs great degrees making
terrible decisions what is missing is
not IQ but wisdom and today it's getting
harder and harder to tap into our own
wisdom because we are all so hyper
connected to our devices or screens or
social media that we're having a hard
time disconnecting from technology and
reconnecting with ourselves
your very own very wise Smith sophomore
Aaron McDaniel wrote in the sofiane
about her decision to disconnect from
all her social media who have as Judy
said real social connections in favor of
superficial technology bridged once we
have become in many
says nearly a socially robotic as our
computers now you don't have the head of
a digital company telling you to
completely disconnect from technology
what I'm telling you is to regularly
disconnect from technology to regularly
unplug and recharge in order to
reconnect with ourselves and our own
deepest wisdom it was actually at
Cambridge when I discovered the
Cambridge Union which was a debating
society and I fell in love with the
spectacle of people's minds and hearts
being moved by words and I said I want
to do that and I was terrible when I
first stood up to speak I was literally
laughed out especially with my thick
Greek accent which was even thicker and
now I had to read every word but at
every debate I would get up often they
would call on me at midnight after they
had exhausted calling on everyone else
and I was just determined to learn to
speak it's still my favorite thing even
though obviously I spend a lot of time
online and running a digital company and
everything 14 books my favorite thing is
speaking in the end it's about how we
feel inside and what is it that
nourishes us and it may not be what our
society values and that's why I love
increasingly we see Millennials
especially turning down the jobs and who
the big salaries and in doing something
like becoming a teacher in an inner-city
school because that's what fuels them in
a positive way and that's what touches
their heart so when we dare to do that
instead of living someone else's life
really and it's dramatic how everything
changes Socrates said practice death
daily he didn't mean that in a morbid
sense he meant that if we really
consciously realize and remember every
day that we are all going to die then we
live life differently because first of
all we don't sweat the small stuff and
when it comes to death everything is
small stuff it's the same thing you know
that and the Romans thought you know
they would carve on statues and on trees
mmm memento mori remember death again
it's one of the say I am we actually
have now a dedicated reporter on the
Huffington Post covering death because
again that's the gain a huge silence in
our culture that the thing that is the
absolutely inevitable part of our lives
is not being covered by the media the
Columbia Journalism Review his first
name is Kjell weed if you don't if you
can't over his last name he's that he's
doing amazing things around death in our
religion section which is next to a
science section because increasingly
we're trying to to see how the two are
not opposed to each other you know
dogmas may be opposed but the heart of
every religion is very connected to the
heart of huge scientific discoveries
yeah so my point to go back to death
and is that if we make it part of life
it will make us lead life differently
and so when the time comes for us to die
we will be prepared for it yeah because
we practiced it because you'll have
practiced it every day and and my advice
to everybody is look at a child and see
how a child handles being upset or angry
I don't believe in in the end growing a
thick skin I think that stops you from
really being permeable and feeling
everything to the full fullest but a
child you know will get really upset and
really cry and they're like five minutes
later it says that nothing's happened
that's what I love I love I love to live
life like that okay it's probably okay
to be upset and angry and irritated but
how long do you stay on it that's for me
the keys like can you say next and move
on and now
hold grudges that's the other key oh my
god Hodgdon grudges is the worst it's a
big part of the political landscape did
you have to learn to do that to let go
oh yeah I don't know I worked at it and
I really believe in it it's a can can
tell it's the most do anything we can do
in our lives he's hauled onto something
other than upset or anger or judgments
you know I like what the Bible says
they've loved today's enough you know
let the dead bury the dead you know move
on like that's that's my advice
everybody well first of all I prioritize
sleep and that means making that means
saying no to things you want to do it's
not easy there's hard I think in our
testing yeah last night and you know
shall sun-baked interviewed me at the
summers go Symphony Hall and then I had
to sign books and I would have loved to
go and have dinner with her but I went
to bed and you know because if I hadn't
got if I'd gone out to dinner and hadn't
got my at least seven hours sleep that I
need and had to get a bell to do TV
I would not be enjoying being here with
you now and I'm really enjoying it and
no one person present I'm not tired and
I hate being tired more than I hate
anything if you really want to be
creative I've just go read in a Steve
Steve judges my over Steve Jobs
biography by brother Isaacson water in
which Steve Jobs as how it was when she
was in meditation that often a lot of
his best ideas for Apple came to him
yeah he calls it being able to listen to
the whisperings yeah that otherwise we
we are really to be
it's too much static in our lives to
listen to that yeah beautiful and Bill
Gates you know he would have his what he
called think weeks when she would take a
week off without any devices and go to a
cabin and think and again to go back to
another Greek you know I always go back
to the Greeks who came up with his
Eureka moment in the boss you know often
how often don't to have a most creative
ideas in the shower or a bath at the
moment our societies nor shall of
success is largely composed of two parts
money and power
in fact success money and power have
practically become synonymous but it's
time for a third metric beyond money and
power one founded on well-being wisdom
our ability to wonder and to give back
you know money and power by themselves I
like it two legged stool you can't
balance on them for a while but
eventually you're going to topple over
and more and more people very successful
people are toppling over every day
basically success the way we've defined
it is no longer sustainable it's not
sustainable for human beings it's not
sustainable for the planet thank you so
much for watching I made this video
because Afghans asked me to so there's a
famous entrepreneur that you want me to
profile next leave it in the comments
below and I'll see what I can do I'd
also love to know which of Huffington's
top ten rules meant the most to you had
the biggest impact leaving the comments
below and I'll join the discussion thank
you so much for watching continue to
believe and I'll see you soon